what are the conditions for talking
about causality there are two conditions
for causality number one there is a
significant correlation between the
variables this is easy to check we
simply check whether the correlation
coefficient is significantly different
from zero number two the second
condition can be met in three ways first
chronological sequence there is a
chronological sequence and the results
of one variable occurred before the
results of the other variable second
experiment a controlled experiment was
conducted in which the two variables can
be specifically influenced and number
three Theory there is a well-founded and
plausible theory in which direction the
cause or relationship goes if there is
only a significant correlation but none
of the other three conditions are met we
can only speak of correlation never of
causality thanks for watching and I hope
you enjoyed the video